I said if my kid ever told me
he wanted to be a comic,
I would go in the other room
and get a gun
and I'd walk back
in the living room
and just look him in the eyes
and go be funny
and fucking end it.
Oh yeah.
[crosstalk 00:00:08]
fucking sell out. That kid
would be on top of comedy.
Joining us, he'll be headlining
Go Bananas in Cincinnati
tomorrow through
Saturday gobananascomedy.com,
Sean Patton.
How are you?
Hey, welcome back to the show.
Hey, yeah I think last time
I was here you were both
going to Cincinnati.
Whoa.
The next day
because we had a flight.
We were.
And we both got upgraded
and I was shocked by how,
and I don't mean to put
your business out there,
how nervous of a flyer you are.
Yeah, [inaudible 00:00:42].
I didn't know that.
I was surprised, surprised.
I was surprised.
So surprised.
[crosstalk 00:00:47].
Super surprised.
Because I'm a nervous flyer
but I hide it well.
Yeah.
I hide it pretty well
unless it gets ...
That might have been
a particularly rocky ride
or something-
So if it gets rocky at all,
you get tense?
I feel like but you-
Look I hold it in pretty good
but if it starts going ...
Also depending on my mood.
Sometimes I'm ready to die.
If I'm having a bad day
on the land,
put me in the sky,
see what happens.
I get up there, I go today
it's gonna happen.
Bring it on, air bitch.
That was a good week then,
because you seemed
pretty nervous.
I don't want to die.
I don't want to die that week.
Things are going well this week.
That week I was not into dying.
I don't like that guy though,
who in those moments
they'll say there's ...
You're safer up here than ...
Shut the fuck [crosstalk
00:01:30].
Stop being negative
to make this a positive.
One of them, with a bunch
of other random people on it
were driven into a fucking
building, so shit happens.
Yeah. Sometimes that fucking
plane does go down
and then you can't find
that guy to be like hey.
Isn't it funny what you
put on it though?
Like the city also, you're like
the one that's gonna go ...
Forget even terrorism.
Let's just talk the thing,
the big national story,
you're like it's never gonna
be going from Greensboro,
South Carolina-
It is though.
To like ... In your mind,
it's not going to be,
but exactly.
It's Malaysian flight whatever.
Just a random flight
that you just fucking ...
That guy who's not afraid
of flying and talks about it,
I hope that person
is in a plane crash
and everyone survives
except him.
Isn't that an Alanis
Morissette lyric?
No, that's-
Isn't it ironic?
Don't you think?
One of her non ironic,
ironic ones.
Non ironic, ironic.
The only ironic part
of that song is its existence.
That's the whole thing.
It's a whole work.
It actually is-
Thank you, Becky [inaudible
00:02:31].
Thank you. From a straight up
grammatical sense,
it is a perfect lesson in irony.
She was attempting
to be ironic and failed-
Do you think she was
that obtuse with the song?
I think that's probably how dumb
a lot of the record execs
are too.
They don't know
what irony actually ...
They're like this is great,
this is smart-
I love it. She's an angel.
People are gonna learn.
People are learning.
People are learning about irony.
We're learning about platinum
albums,
because she's making them.
Jagged Little Pill
[crosstalk 00:02:56].
Here's a spoon.
He goes, isn't that ironic?
I need a knife.
He goes, I just met the guy
of my dreams
and his beautiful wife.
That's his wife.
Are you gay? Yes.
Is that ironic?
Don't you think?
It's like rain ...
I'm trying to think
about the lyrics.
Why would I get in this cab?
I'm already late.
My plane's crashing.
I go isn't that nice?
I've been afraid to do this.
We were talking before
the break,
before you came in about-
Porn?
No. That was yesterday.
I do also hate it when you find
a no smoking sign
on your cigarette break.
Just go smoke anywhere else.
Knowing my luck, I'll win the
lotto and then die the next day.
Right?
Am I right?
Am I right or am I wrong?
Before the break,
we were talking about men
with dual families,
with two families.
We were talking about
having a shitty father-
You mean like Gambion Bonanno,
you belong to both-
No, not crime families.
Actual platonic-
Having a shitty father like me
and Dan and Isabella over here.
I think you've seen
the recipient
of the second generation award.
You've seen what my work
has done there.
There it is.
We're talking about if you have
shitty dad, you want to be-
Like you have step siblings,
is that what you're saying?
No. I'm saying you want
to be a better ...
If you were to have a kid ...
Luis was an example of that.
Luis J. Gomez, great father.
Really tough.
Had a dad that got murdered,
was not in his life
and then he's a great dad.
We were saying how fucked up-
He's at least a living dad.
He's a living dad.
He's alive.
My thought was, I think
what would fuck me up
psychologically more than having
a dead dad would be having a dad
that's alive with another family
and hiding it from you,
like living with you
at your house
and with your mom and then goes
and has another family.
Like Lifetime movie-
There's a character on Billions,
dollar bill, that has that.
My dad dd do that ...
Your dad went out
and was a single swanky swinger.
Dude, he fucking was
an indoor cat
and they let him outside
and he did not come home.
[crosstalk 00:05:01]
I'm an outdoor cat now.
Dan's dad, he wore sunglasses
at night for sure.
My dad definitely had ...
I remember-
Is your dad still alive,
do you know?
No. My dad died when I was 14.
Oh shit.
Yeah. He went out.
Him and Luis's dad
killed each other.
Yeah, in a duel. It was pretty-
Of age, or another STD or-
I wish. Not far.
Hep C that turned
into cirrhosis.
Really?
That eventually became
AIDS posthumously.
He got Hep C from [crosstalk
00:05:27].
His ashes got AIDS.
I hope he got the Hep C
from a dirty tattoo needle
where he was getting his
other family's name tattooed.
Dude, that would've been great.
He's getting Skip,
his favorite son.
His other son that
I don't know about.
That's where he got the Hep C.
[crosstalk 00:05:46].
It's actually Marquis
and that is your brother.
He is actually a D1 prospect.
On some level, that would be
ironic, dying from that tattoo.
Isn't it ironic?
He got it, I think banging some
piece of fucking lake trash.
Which lake? Lake Tahoe?
Clear Lake in
northern California-
Ironically title Clear Lake
is where he got some
[crosstalk 00:06:12].
Murky as fuck.
He fucked a wide mouthed bass.
My dad was into fish.
He was like Troy McClure.
My dad had the Troy McClure
sexual fetish.
Dan's dad used to go
[okie 00:06:25]
noodling his dick.
He goes do you want to go-
Got a catfish? Hang on. Hang on.
Arms up. I feel it.
Yo, there he is.
He goes you want to go to
the fish market
and just look around?
I like the idea of your dad
banging a rainbow trout
to a Phish album.
I'm gonna make this
last the whole solo.
Have you ever had tantric
Phish sex?
You fuck as long
as they jam.
Rainbow trout and I ain't gay.
I ain't no gay fish. Bestiality-
What's crazy is that my dad got
Hep C from this lady
and it killed him
but it also killed his sister
because she was a nurse,
my aunt.
She came to take care of him
and he threw up blood
and it got in her eye,
and she got Hep C.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Then last Thanksgiving,
when I'm at my grandma's-
That's back when Dan's dad
was dating hepatitis
Cheryl.
Hep Cheryl.
That sounds like a bad scene
in Oz.
[crosstalk 00:07:19].
What's your name?
He goes my name's AIDS Jay.
What are you in for?
Gonorrhea Gary.
A lot of bloody stuff.
A lot of-
I bleed a lot so I leave
a lot of evidence behind.
I also finger paint
with my blood.
It's a whole thing.
This is fucked up-
Anyway, I usually cover myself
in my own semen or whatever.
This is fucked up
but it made me laugh.
I always play cards
with my grandma when I see her,
and there's no TV in that room,
but college football is always
on because it's Thanksgiving.
So I'll keep the TV on to listen
to what college
football game is going on.
My grandma and I
are playing cards
and it's like I cured
my hepatitis C in 14 days,
and I'm like hey, nana.
Trying to distract her.
Over here.
Both of her kids got taken out
by this disease
that this commercial
is just talking shit about,
where it's like I cured it
Scott free in a week.
My grandma's like gin.
Every time I hear it, it gives
me warm fuzzies all over again.
You are a fantastic grandson.
Thanks man.
You really are.
Wait. What do you mean?
Every year, at least once-
Plays cards with the grandma.
I go out-
He goes out there and spends
like a weekend there.
Yeah, but I'm all she has.
In Colorado?
No. In northern San Francisco,
Lake County-
He really does
what he's just saying.
He's sitting there,
playing gin rummy.
Did you say Lake County?
Lake County.
Get away from the lake man.
My grandma lives on the lake.
Move her out of there.
She likes it.
All of her old friends are there
and they're all dying.
[crosstalk 00:08:47].
Is she still fucking
hepatitis Carl?
I go Hep Emmett.
You have an old man.
Hepatitis Emmett comes around
every once in awhile.
Oh my Herman.
Are there other hepatitises
of the other 25 letters
of the alphabet?
There's A and B.
There is A and B?
A you get from eating shit
or you can get it from food.
I thought B, you can also get
from eating shit-
B, B, B, go Bayside. B, B, B.
C is the dead.
C gets you but now
they can cure it.
My dad died of it in '97
and my aunt died of it in '07,
and she extended her life.
She was boozing.
Aunt Karen could rip it.
Would you travel back in time
with the cure to cure your dad,
or would you let him go?
That's a good question.
Did you have any love
for your father at all?
Yeah. I would cure it.
Just to talk shit.
So I could fight him.
Just fight him.
Like a boy named Sue.
Gary, I'm gonna cure you
and then I'm gonna kick
the shit out you.
That's a great fucking country
song right there.
How do you do?
My name is hepatitis Dan.
I would go back and save him.
Spell Sue with a C
and and umlaut on top.
I would definitely save my aunt.
Sue, [crosstalk 00:10:06].
If I had to go pick ...
If you made me choose
my aunt or my dad,
that would be tougher.
This is a great-
Sophie's choice.
Version of this song.
I went and traveled back
in time with the cure
for Hep C, found my dad-
Found my dad drinking at a bar.
It was the bowling alley
I worked at.
I walked in, I said-
I said hey dad, I missed you.
He said it's 5:00 somewhere.
He said I'm at Margaritaville,
who are you?
What's your name?
It's the big headed kid
I had with the mean bitch.
[inaudible 00:10:42].
Big headed kid.
I noticed you're staring down
at my-
The bitch I thought
was a big mouth bass.
I thought she was a fish.
Turns out she was Irish.
I bet your looking down at my
quarter length socks
into some slides but ...
Dude, my dad didn't wear socks.
At all.
No. My dad wore boat shoes
and fucking corduroy shorts
with no underwear.
I love boat shoes. It's great.
[crosstalk 00:11:07].
My dad dressed for cirrhosis.
They say dress
for the disease you want.
My dad dressed ...
I wear a lot of scarves
on my head prepping for cancer.
I go around jaunt in sweatpants
for an AIDS day.
A lot of jackets,
I'm dressing for scurvy.
Get some lime.
My dad didn't wear socks
and no underwear.
I believe it.
Were his feet ripe?
No. He had like
tough islander feet.
They don't smell anymore
because they don't sweat
[crosstalk 00:11:44].
He burned all the sweat glands.
Also he's just drinking
enough alcohol
to sterilize
anything on his body.
I'm surprised my dad didn't-
Your dad sweats iodine.
I'm so surprised it didn't cure
the Hep C the second
it touched his fucking
alcohol rich bloodstream.
Just catches on fire.
Hep C, you say?
I'll knock that out by tonight.
Yeah.
Sometimes I get it
when I'm bored.
I just watch it-
To have something to do.
I heal like Wolverine.
I go out there, give myself
lockjaw just for fun.
Just do it.
What's your dad's name?
Dean?
Gary. That's why
we're sons of Gary.
He has a shitty dad
named Gary too.
That's why we're so close.
My dad's name is Tim.
He's pretty cool.
Tim does sound
like a good dad name.
Tim's a good dad name-
Tim Patton?
Tim Patton. Good guy.
Tim Patton and his kids
are coming over.
I'd be like
I fucking love Tim.
Were either of you guys
doing moon tower
that year that they gave
everyone flesh lights?
Yeah.
I wasn't there that year.
I was there that year.
You were.
Everybody pretended like
they didn't
go immediately
to their room and use it.
I was very open about it.
Everyone pretended,
like no I didn't.
[crosstalk
00:12:48].
I was embarrassed that
I didn't finish in it.
I think I've owned two.
I've never utilized either.
I felt like a serial killer.
I bet.
You see the rubber moving.
You're like what is this?
Is this an organ?
Is this a dead person's organ?
It's fucking weird.
Which mount did you use?
What do you mean?
They had the vaginal opening,
the anal opening
and then just the slit.
I didn't know that.
I just opened the top like
a thermos and it was there.
You must have not got
the deluxe.
I didn't get the deluxe.
Damn dude.
That's when you're a headliner
at moon tower.
Then every-
I was also at the Radisson.
Did all the Radisson people get-
I was at the Radisson.
It's like a Rambo knife.
Oh my god, there's a compass
on the bottom.
There's a whole sewing kit,
tweezers.
You can stitch up a wound-
There's a corkscrew in there.
You can open-
There's one single match.
A blue tip though.
You can light it on anything.
Strike anywhere.
They recommend you open
a bottle of wine with it,
while using it.
Don't you understand,
this dildo is the best?
Everyone just left them
in the hotel rooms?
It can fuck things
that make a Billy goat.
I know because I trained it.
Colonel [Troutman 00:13:57].
I gave a good job
in amateur porn.
Of course, you know that knife.
That dildo is built by the best.
Was that Stallone you just did?
That was his Rambo.
Particularly my Rambo.
It's Stallone
in the key of Rambo.
Key of. Can't even get a job
parking the fucking cars.
I still have never seen
the first Rambo.
You've never seen
First Blood?
I know. I've only seen the one
where he's in the jungle.
No.
We had one of the most fun ...
Best one is First Blood-
First Blood is easily
the best one.
Don't blow it yet.
We just do a fun thing
on the [crosstalk
00:14:34].
Joe DeRosa has a very
interesting take on
First Blood.
That's a little preview
for the lost at sea tapes,
that we recorded on
the Impractical Jokers cruise.
Were you guys both there?
Yeah.
Just living ...
Do you want to talk about it?
We have a bunch of episodes
that we recorded on the boat.
Fun hang though.
DeRosa was there?
Fun hang.
He didn't jump off?
We thought he might have
Saturday night.
I thought last night
he was gonna go for it.
He was sad. He was sad drunk and
he's like everyone's mad at me-
He drunkenly thought
everyone was mad at him
at different times.
Then you'd be like I don't think
it's that big of a deal
and he'd go
what did I do, man?
Why me? Why always me?
I'm like it's fine.
I don't think
it's that big of a deal.
He goes what did I do, man?
Then he'd always come back
15 minutes later
and go they said they were
joking, they weren't mad at me.
Then every time
you talked to Nate or I,
it was like do you want to play
craps or go get ice cream?
Yeah, we lived on craps
and ice cream.
I heard this story about him
at Edinburgh a few years ago-
Nate?
No, about DeRosa,
that his roommates kept
putting dead bees in his room
just to hear him freak out.
That's really funny.
Who were his roommates?
Ari was one of them.
Ari is the one
who told me this story
and then I forgot the other, two
Brits I think-
Just some Scottish guy.
They had-
This guy, a soft bodied man
loses his shit hearing
a dead bee in his bed.
He can't handle a wasp.
Let's find one of those.
Damn near throws
his glasses at it.
You can literally hear
a man's head explode.
Come here [crosstalk
00:16:04].
Bees.
No bees.
It's great.
You want to see a man
fly through the roof?
Like a bee himself.
Hey. You should leave
a comment below.
One of us might be in a
depression spiral and read it.
Oh.
It might just push us
all the way down.
Yeah. Yeah.
I can get pretty dark.
It's weird.
I look forward to reading it.